puis minuit qui le royaume uni impose
une quatorzaine atouf les voyageurs
étrangers arrivant sur le sol
britannique sous peine d'une amende de
1000 livres
une mesure décriée notamment par les
compagnies aériennes et une décision qui
intervient dans un contexte tendu avec
l'union européenne
claire nico si vous aviez prévu de
séjourner prochainement au royaume uni
il faut compter à partir d'aujourd'hui
14 jours de quarantaine
à votre arrivée sur le sol britannique
et justifier un lieu de résidence durant
cette période une nouvelle mesure
annoncée mercredi 3 juin par la ministre
britannique de l'intérieur au parlement
pour limiter la propagation de
l'infection les arrivants doivent
s'isoler pendant 14 jours
il s'agit de la période d'incubation du
coronavirus qui suit l'avis d'un expert
médical est conforme à la période d'auto
isolement du service de test et de
traçage du nhs pour toute personne ayant
été en contact avec la maladie cette
nouvelle mesure accompagne un
déconfinement progressif qui a commencé
depuis le 1er juin dernier déjà vivement
critiqué par l'opposition travailliste
et certains députés conservateurs c'est
surtout l'industrie du tourisme qui tire
la sonnette d'alarmé dans une lettre
commune adressée au gouvernement
britannique plusieurs compagnies
aériennes dont british airways ryanair
et easyjet affirme que cette décision
aura des conséquences catastrophiques
pour le secteur un secteur déjà quasi
paralysée pendant le confinement l'effet
d'instaurer une restriction totalement
injustifiée disproportionnée sur les
personnes entrant en angleterre est
discutable mans le royaume uni et
signifiera inévitablement qu'il y aura
une très faible augmentation du nombre
de personnes quittant et entrant dans le
pays
mais le gouvernement britannique
envisage la mise en place de pont aérien
avec certains pays ainsi les voyageurs
arrivant de graisse d'australie ou
encore du portugal pourrait éviter cette
quarantaine des nouvelles mesures qui
interviennent dans un contexte tendu
entre l'union européenne et le royaume
uni vendredi lors du quatrième cycle de
négociations sur le bric site michel
barnier le négociateur de l'union
européenne pour le bric site déploré
l'absence de progrès significatifs vers
les cieux ce tour ces différents points
comme
autre nous ne demandons rien d'autre que
le respect de la déclaration politique
sur ces poids il n'y a donc pas eu de
progrès significatifs depuis le début de
la négociation
je pense que nous ne pourrons pas
continuer éternellement comme ça la
perspective d'un odile refait donc
surface alors que la date fatidique du
31 décembre 2020 se rapproche